(smooth, jazzy music)
- Don't talk to me before
I've had a sip of coffee.
(ding)
The last person who talked
to me before I had coffee,
(beep) Don't touch me before coffee.
Went missing.
Some people are scared
of me but, whatever.
- A drink should be refreshing,
it should be like ooh,
cool refreshing drink,
not ow my mouth's on fire.
(ding)
When it's hot I can walk around
with my iced coffee and
no one will judge me,
and when it's cold, people
are like what are you doing.
I love it.
- So I drink my coffee black.
No, no sugar, no milk, no frill.
(ding)
I just go to work.
Just very plain.
Zero games on my phone.
You know what I do, I read news.
That's it.
(hissing)
- I know everything about coffee,
I am like the coffee
connoisseur, sommelier, so.
Coffee's not easy, it's not simple.
(ding)
I've been studying the art
of coffee for, (exhales)
17 years now.
So we require all of our suppliers
to pick the beans by feet.
It just tastes, you'll notice it
once you develop the coffee palate.
Typically roasting just, in my experience,
destroys the flavor of the bean,
so we toast here, yeah.
- Hi, may I please have an
iced grande iced coffee,
no classic, with a little
bit of half and half?
(ding)
I mean yeah, people say
I'm a coffee addict,
but I read the New York
Times, they say it's fine,
like no one's proven
anything wrong with coffee,
I don't think anything's
wrong with coffee.
Hi again, iced grande
iced coffee, no classic,
with a little bit of skim milk.
About five sounds about normal a day,
I mean this is, I'm up to three,
so I think I could go up, you know,
five is a good stopping point.
Barista, regular?
Yeah, I'll probably cut off around five.
(dripping)
- I'm more of a slow, easygoing person,
and I'm just not trying to
be off the top all the time.
(ding)
I mean yeah, a lot of older people
drink decaffeinated coffee but I mean,
I guess I'm kinda like an old soul myself.
I don't need help staying awake.
I enjoy resting.
I mean, isn't that normal?
I never miss a night's sleep.
Not with this.
- I love coffee, but I don't
want to overpollute my body.
(ding)
Hi, I want an almond milk latte,
how many calories is in that one?
For me it's really important
that the milk is organic.
Almond milk, soy milk, hemp milk.
I'm in the process of trying
to cleanse my body right now
so I don't want to pollute it
with other unhealthy sugars.
- Hi, can I have a large
French vanilla coffee
with lots of skim milk and three sugars?
So I like the idea of coffee,
but I need to have a lot of
milk in it, and a lot of sugar,
because I don't love the taste of it.
(ding)
Actually, can it just be
more of like a milkshake?
Just a little bit of
coffee in it, like a drop?
It is not enough milk.
Let's pour out half of that.
- I love coffee, but no more.
Because, I've been getting a
lot of headaches and stuff.
(ding)
I'm trying to quit coffee.
It's been surprisingly hard.
If I was drinking coffee
still, which I'm not, tea,
I really like light roasts actually,
because you don't know this,
and it's kinda counterintuitive
but light roasts tend to
have more caffeine in them,
so you'd be getting
more bang for your buck.
Me?
No, I, I don't miss coffee.
If anything, coffee misses me.
- [Black Coffee Drinker]
What are you drinking?
- [Other Woman] Oh, um, it's tea.
- You're drinking tea?
What are you even doing here?
It's a coffee shop.
Get out of here.